Okay.
We have a voicemail today.
The voicemail, a number of course is two one
nine two, David P a.
Remember that you can call the voicemail number
anytime of day.
You might recall a couple of months ago we
heard from a retired psychiatric nurse who
had some insights into Donald Trump's possible
condition.
She is back on the voicemail line today.
There was the suggestion from some viewers
a week or so ago that Donald Trump may be
suffering from tardive dyskinesia.
The psychiatric nurse explains, this is unlikely.
Let's take a listen.
Hi David.
This is Catherine retired psych nurse.
I um, wanted you to know that part of dyskinesia
is a result of, um, medications that are used
to treat psychosis.
There was a first anti-psychotic meds, um,
around and they had terrible side effects.
Um, most of them are no longer in use.
Uh, and also I noticed for a long time that
Donald Trump has extremely limited range of
motion in his neck.
You know, he can't turn his head to decide.
He kind of turns his whole shoulder.
So I don't know if that's related to anything,
but it isn't.
Try a dyskinesia, which is a repetitive and
voluntary movement and uh, it's really a shame
when people have that and you don't usually
see it anymore.
So thanks very much.
I listened to you show off and take care.
All right.
Always great to hear from Catherine giving
us insights immediately.
It seems as though we can, we can write off
this possibility of tardive dyskinesia.
You know, I have noticed that Donald Trump
does do that thing where he will sort of brace
on his lectern at speeches and he will kind
of turn his entire sort of like from the breastbone
up when he looks to the side and I'd never
made much of it, but Catherine pointing out
that that is a little bit unusual.
That's a always great to hear from Catherine
and it seems to be a continued mystery.
What w what is the full list of conditions
which may be afflicting Donald Trump?
Will we ever know?
Not if Trump has anything to say about it.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about new laws coming
this year in 2020 various state laws that
you may find interesting.
We are also going to talk about a Virginia
school district that is giving students a
day off one day off per year for what they
are calling civic engagement.
I think this is fantastic.
We will talk about it.
We will also talk about the hallmark channel.
This was a big controversy for a lot of right-wingers.
The hallmark channel has reversed its decision
to pull a commercial that has a same sex couple
in it.
They initially made the decision to pull it.
They've reversed the decision.
And this is part of, I hate using the term
culture war because it is a trumped up term
meant to create a particular, uh, it has a
very narrow meaning the way it's used, but
there are cultural elements that are important
to what is going on here, which I want to
discuss all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show.
Two ways to get instant access to the bonus
show in 2020 number one become a member.
We have some members who are about to embark
on their 10th years as David Pakman show.
Members embark on your first year
by signing up@jointbatmandotcomormakeapledgeonpatrionatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
I'll speak [inaudible] the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].